so I'm gonna continue the theme on on
play cells and I'm going to talk about
work that I completed as a postdoc in
Van Daan vex lab last year before I
started my own lab at the University of
Chicago and we're interested in how
place fields form or the mechanisms that
underlie play sport formation when an
animal experiences a novel environment
and in particular we're interested in
active dendritic signals given their
role at least the brain slices induced
in synaptic plasticity in the presence
of appropriately timed presynaptic input
and so to do this kind of experiment to
get at these questions we use a
combination of behavior in virtual
reality with calcium imaging of large
populations of hippocampal cells and
also sub cellular mechanisms such as
dendrites and axons so here's a typical
experiment where these head fixed mice
are trained to navigate along these
virtual linear tracks and their water
rewarded when they hit the wall at the
end and they're teleported back to the
beginning of the track so they can
complete many many laps of this virtual
space and so while the animals doing
this we can image up to a thousand ca1
pyramidal neurons during this behavior
so each one of these little donut shaped
structures here is a single neuron
expressing a genetically encoded calcium
indicator so these changes in
fluorescence depict action potential
firing in each one of these neurons so
we can define which cells have spatially
tuned firing properties in the virtual
environment and then we can adapt this
technique slightly so to obtain
expression of this gcamp
six in a sparse population of ca1
neurons so this is the same field of
viewers up here but only a few cells are
expressing the indicator and what that
allows us to do is image single
dendritic branches that come from these
neurons
so we have this electric lens that
allows us to rapidly switch our image
imaging plane from the somatic layer to
the basal dendritic layer and that's
what I'm showing you here so it's
essentially gives us a simultaneous
readout of the dendritic activity along
with the somatic activity so together
this this experimental setup allows us
to ask questions a population level and
at a subcellular dendritic level and so
the first thing we want to know is
whether switching the virtue environment
to a novel novel environment causes
global remapping in the hippocampus so
this is a phenomena that's seen in
real-world environments when an animal
is placed in two distinct environments
so we want to test that when we change
the virtual environment this also
induces global remapping in the
hippocampus and so we trained our
animals to run in a familiar environment
and we can image a population of primal
neurons and then we can define which
cells over the population have
significant place fields of that
environment so I'm depicting 78 placed
cells across the population and we can
plot the mean place build activity of
each one of these neurons and show that
they tile the virtual track this is
track position in this virtual
environment and so we've sorted them by
and they tile the entire linear track so
what we can do is we can teleport the
animal to a new environment that the
animal hasn't experienced before so the
animal again has to run down the track
and the track length is the same as in
the first environment we can ask what
happens to the place cells that encoded
the first environment in the second
environment what you can see from this
this plot here is that the place builds
become scrambled across across the
population so for example place where
one here loses its place field it has no
statistically significant place field in
the new environment and other place
fields shift around somewhat random to
random locations in the new
so this is a signature that global
remapping has occurred across the
hippocampus and we saw this in every
single Mouse that we did this experiment
in and so this is our experimental
setups and now we can look at the
formation of these new place fields as
the animal is experienced in the new
environment so here's two example place
fields that appeared in the northern
environment the one on the left here so
this is lap number in the novel
environments this is lat one the animal
hasn't experienced this place before and
you can see that there's a place field
that appears instantly in that novel
environment and remains pretty much in
the same place throughout the experience
as opposed to this kind of place field
that appears after a delay period so
there's no somatic firing for about the
first 10 laps and then there's a abrupt
onset of a place field after some
experience these these are delayed
forming place builds and these have been
seen by some Lauren Frank showed this in
2004 in real world environments that you
can see these instantly forming place
fields and in other place fields that
were delayed in time and so we we
quantified this across all our place
cells across all our animals and so what
you're with what we're seeing here in
this histogram is the place field
formation lap that's the where the place
would first appeared over the novel
environment experience and about 50
percent of place field seems to have an
instant place field that appears on the
first lap and about 50 percent are
delayed by some number of laps but
overall it takes at least in this
preparation about 15 laps before the
entire ensemble shows significant place
fields and this takes about 3 to 4
minutes to develop so as an ensemble we
see instant place fields and we see
these delayed onset place fields that
take about three to four minutes to form
so now we want to ask well what role do
active dendrites play on a single neuron
level in the formation of these place
fields
and so before I get into the details I
want to show you the kinds of signals
that we're able to detect in the
dendrites of ca1 pyramidal cells in vivo
and so here it's hard to see on this on
this slide actually but here's a basal
dendritic branch here it's actually
easier to look on the screen over here
so here's a well now the well you can
see the branch and you can see single
spines hanging off the side of this this
single dendritic branch this is a basal
dendrite and we can make regions of
interest around different parts of the
branch and we can image these branches
during behavior so imagine the animal is
running around you see this single
branch here and we see this calcium
transient that's restricted to the spine
head and so we think that these kinds of
signals are caused by a single synaptic
input onto that spine head and the
activation of NMDA receptors at least
partial activation and the influx of
calcium through those receptor channels
and that's opposed to these kinds of
events where we see this is the same
branch here where we see calcium influx
throughout the whole imaged branch and
so we think that the source of calcium
in these events is through voltage-gated
calcium channels that are found along
that along the shaft there and these are
a signature that a regenerative branch
spike event has occurred in that branch
and so given that these provide powerful
depolarization to the branch at least in
brain slices and can cause synaptic
potentiation under the right conditions
we seek to measure these cut branch
spike events in place fields and so one
of the branches are single branches or
disintegrate in this example here this
is just a single branch so we're zoomed
into one branch we want to see what
kinds of signals we could the other
showing on this we can't see them under
these conditions these are these somatic
spikes we don't we don't know under
these conditions we don't know because
they're not image in the soma but in
this experiment we're doing a larger
field of view so we're imaging five
branches along with the soma so we're
moving from the soma plane to the
dendritic plane very rapidly and this
time the animal is actually behaving
along the virtual track and this the
activity in this cell is has is in its
place field so what you see and this is
on repeat we see activation of the soma
presumably a bunch of action potentials
as firing there to cause this magnitude
of calcium influx and simultaneously in
these five image branches we see branch
spike in this co-occurring with the soma
and we still don't know if these are
caused by back propagation or whether
they're locally generated we don't have
the temporal resolution but what we can
say is they're co-occurring with the
soma and so this wasn't exactly
surprising firing in the soma spiking in
the dendrites but what we did find that
was surprising was in the same neuron on
a subsequent lab we could we saw a
similar magnitude calcium transient in
the soma presumably caused by a similar
level of action potential firing but a
complete absence of branch spiking in
those image dendrites at least so our
conclusion here was that the branch
spiking in the dendrites is somewhat
independent of somatic firing and his
head of a genius in a single neuron from
place field traversal to place build
traversal and can go up and down and
with each lap so what we did in this
paper so this was all done while the
animal was traversing a familiar
environment we could group cells into
different categories based on how many
Brown spikes or how prevalent branch
spiking was in the place field and we
found that those neurons that had high
branch spiking prevalence on average in
the place field had more precise and
stable place fields over time relative
to the ones that had lower branch
spiking and so our next question was
whether this this these branch spikes
role in the formation of new place
builds and so here's an example of a
neuron where we Co imaged the basal
dendrites and the same and here's what
it looks like in the field of view now
the animal is experience and not is
experience in a novel environment and
let me walk you through these traces so
this black trace here is the animal's
position in the virtual linear space so
this is an example of a single lap
through the virtual environment the gray
in the background is the mean somatic
place field that's quantified over many
laps and these are example traces from
this single lap so here's the soma and
the nine image branches from up here so
what you can see is there's a somatic
calcium transient in the place field on
this lap this is lap eight in the novel
environment and we see this co-occurring
branch spiking across all those image
dendrites as opposed to this lap on lap
26 here we see a somatic calcium
transient we see the absence of branch
spiking across the arbor this is the
head of Jannetty that I just showed you
in the movie on the last slide and then
on his third example we see a single
branch spike in the dendrites during
somatic firing so the question we had
was whether these brown spike in this
branch spike in prevalence where they
had dynamics that changed during the
novel environment experience and so we
plotted the average branch spike
prevalence versus the lap number in the
novel environment what we found was the
in in place fields that branch spiking
was a lot higher during the first few
traversals in in the novel environment
when the place field first appeared and
so we think that these branch spikes are
providing a postsynaptic depolarization
necessary to cause synaptic potentiation
x' under the right conditions and so
you're more likely to get synaptic
strength and in earlier on during the
novel experience
emergence of these somatic that's the
next part of this so this is all so far
showing you what the brand spikes are
doing when the place field first appears
when the somatic place bill first
appears but the next question is for
these delayed onset place fields is
there anything going on in the bend
rights that could be driving their
formation and so we looked for localized
branch spikes that can occur in the
absence of somatic firing that might be
causing changes in synaptic strength
during the delay period and so here's
what one of these spikes looks like in
an ex-vivo brain slice prep so this is a
a basal dendrite from ca1 pyramidal
neuron and it's expressing gcamp six and
we are driving this localized dendritic
spike by uncaging glutamate on a
clustered set of synapses and so you can
see here if you if we drive seven spines
close in time and clustered close
together we can generate one of these
localized dendritic spikes that look
similar to what other people have seen
in the brain slice preparations so next
we look for the signature of these of
these spikes in the in vivo condition so
this is another basal dendrite and the
animal is now running around in the
virtual environment and you can see a
localized branch spike in the absence of
somatic firing that looks similar to the
ex vivo brain slice prep so now the
question is do these occur before the
appearance of delayed onset placement
and could they be driving them and so
just to reiterate the kinds of signals
we can see in a single branch here's the
branch at rest his a localized spine
transient here's the entire branch
lighting up and here's a localized
dendritic spike and it's these that
we're looking for and they occur in the
absence of somatic firing and so do they
research during this period which called
the delay period and we asked when we
detect these branch spikes and we
detected 30 of them across seven mice
and 11 place fields where do they occur
in the virtual environment relative to
the future
maduk place filled and that's what's
shown in this histogram here these green
this green indicates all the dendritic
spikes that we saw across the
environment across all land my sorry and
these dashed lines represent the future
somatic place field location so what you
can see is that most dendritic spikes
that we see occur in the track at the
position where the somatic place will
eventually form so we think that these
signals are providing the postsynaptic
depolarization necessary for certain
forms of synaptic potentiation and then
drive the firing of that neuron in that
particular location I forget what are
the inputs of the dendrites is that
primarily ca3 it was primarily ca3 yeah
and so the next question we had was in
at least in brain slice preparations
these signals are highly dependent on
the levels of inhibition that are
received in the in this dendritic layer
and so we asked whether inhibition
levels to these dendrites changed during
a novel my environment exposure so to do
this we took advantage of these
somatostatin Kree lines that label a
subpopulation of of inter neurons in the
hippocampus some of which have
projections to the basal dendritic layer
of the pyramidal cells that were
interested in this synapse here and so
we measured the level of inhibition in
this basal dendritic region by measuring
the axon activity from these inter
neurons from these labeled internal so
they're expressing gcamp 6 so we can
measure their dynamics and switch the
environment to a new one and see how
inhibition levels change and so this is
what the experiment looks like we have
the animal in the familiar environment
and this is the animal's behavior so
he's running multiple laps through the
familiar environment and you can see
that inhibition levels to the basal
dendrites go up and go down with each
lap so it's it's it's correlated to the
animals movement which is something
that's
before but the important thing here is
when we switch to the novel environment
the level of dendritic inhibition to
these dendrites goes down transiently
for a period of time so we think that
it's this inhibition is is opening up a
window by which these these branch
spikes can occur and cause changes in
synaptic strength and that's true across
all the all the animals that we looked
at and so so far I've talked about these
different mechanisms and how they may
relate to synaptic plasticity so but I
haven't shown you anything to do with
plasticity directly so the next question
we have asked was if we disrupt NMDA
receptors a component that is necessary
for certain forms of PB and potentiation
can we disrupt the formation of
placements so to do this experiment
without getting into too many of the
details we took advantage of these NMDA
knockout mice that are Cree dependent so
we obtained a Cree dependent expression
of our gk6 which are the green neurons
and these are the same neurons that have
their NMDA receptors knocked out so it's
a local knockout in the cells that we're
imaging in the CIA one and so the first
thing we measured was what effect is
knocking out the NMDA receptors have on
the branch spiking activity in the
dendrites and so here's our wild-type
curve in the familiar environment when
we switch to novel we see branch spiking
activity go up it comes down over time
within the knockout Mouse it remains
pretty low throughout the whole
experience and so these branch spikes at
least to a certain extent are dependent
on NMDA receptors and these localized
branch spikes that we saw during the
delay period in the wild-type mice worth
completely absent in the knockout we
didn't see anything
so disrupting the these signals what
does it do to the formation of place
fields so we switched back to our
population imaging so here's our
wild-type on the left and our knockout
on the right here and these green
circles indicate
active neurons regardless of whether
they have place fields or not and you
can see by eye across the two mice that
the number of active cells in the field
of view is about the same but the number
of statistically significant place
fields is much lower in the knockout
mouse relative to the wild-type mouse
although a significant number still fall
and so that's true across across a
number of mice and so what this suggests
is that NMDA receptor synaptic
plasticity is involved in the formation
of at least some neuron someplace fields
in the ca1 region of the hippocampus
although not all and so the plasticity
involved in the formation of these
neurons could be occurring elsewhere or
maybe Plus this that he's not required
at all as I would just like to walk you
through our current working hypothesis
of what we think is occurring so during
a initial exposure to a novel
environment we see two kinds of place
cells we see play cells that are
instantly present in in the environment
and we see a high level of branch
spiking activity which is depicted by
these green branches and this occurs
during lowered inhibition which we think
promotes the increase of these branch
spikes and we also see these delayed
onset play cells and so these neurons
seem to show localized dendritic branch
spikes in their dendrites during this
lowered dendritic inhibition and then
over time would think is the the
synapses that are found on these
branches become strong enough to
eventually cause somatic firing during
also lowering abyssion so the branch
spiking levers are also higher and then
inhibition returns the baseline levels
but their synapses are now strong enough
by themselves to cause Playstore firing
so that's how we think at least a subset
of neurons form their place builds in
the ca1
look are you you'd said earlier that the
branch spikes seem to disappear overlaps
as if after the place healed was learned
presumably by strengthening these
contacts now the branches weren't
generating spikes anymore which is
generated spice but less prevalent less
likely
Ritsu it's it's kind of strange because
you think the synapses are now to have
been potentiated but they're let they're
no longer producing spikes in the same
location so it's almost are you do you
believe that the readouts of the learned
place field is not active responses so I
think that it's I think the potentiation
that occurs across the Arbor is
localized so even though the Pretz are
the prevalent this higher prevalence of
branch spiking could be due to the lower
dendritic inhibition right and increased
back propagation throughout the
dendritic Arbor and so when we measure a
sub sample of those dendrites we see
branch spikes in all of them over time
when the inhibition comes back we see we
still see branch spiking and those may
be occurring on branches that had
synaptic potentiation that occurred on
them but it doesn't spread throughout
the arbor so the prevalence of the
branch spiking goes down it could be it
could be something like that yeah so so
that that's basically our story so far
and this work is ongoing and we're
looking at silence cells that don't form
place fields at all whether
localized dendritic spikes even occur in
those in those cells to see if it's
specific to the cell that form placement
you said that you see more places over
here
and then dendritic squaking goes down
yes
can it be that these new places are
generating more inhibition just because
they're providing feedback yeah yeah
yeah I mean it could be and the source
of the lowered inhibition is unknown at
this point whether it's a feedback or a
feed-forward there's a lot of
neuromodulatory inputs that come into
the hippocampus that change during novel
environment experience and that could be
generating the change in addition if we
don't know exactly where it's coming
from where it's driven by the cells
themselves or not this story from Steve
single bound about that that might be
this long range maybe should projections
into this inhibition in there in the ca1
base inhibition yeah yeah that's what
else what I was thinking about blocking
the astral choline inputs optogenetic
Nancy
experiments you can distinguish between
changes and the total amount of
excitation versus changes so we're not
measuring synaptic plasticity directly
so we're measuring presumably the effect
of it has on the formation of place
bills so we just look we define cells as
active if they show any signs of the
calcium transient across the population
and the activity across the population
doesn't change when you knock out the
NMDA receptors so that's we think the
excitation coming in is similar but it's
the formation of of place fields that
changes so it's presumably the role of
the NMDA receptors is to induce
plasticity rather than drive firing of
the neurons per se yeah um for the cells
that don't have a delayed onset can you
use or something that predicts their
future participation in the sleep
beforehand all right yeah so that would
be an interesting experiment that we
haven't done yeah because I mean I mean
he's shown like there's just like little
things about thresholds something that
that predict the future participation in
correct I'm not sure if it's future and
I think he looks at the future
participation but he is looking at very
similar questions about the formation of
place fields with a different technique
and he's finding that when place fields
first appear he sees these complex
spikes bursts right and these are this
high levels of branch spiking in the
dendrite had been linked to bursting in
neurons so we're probably measuring a
similar thing actually
or delayed environments well how we
measure it is we look for when we first
see activity in the cell that spatially
tuned we just look for lap number we
correlate it to lap number environment
nama very much oh that's such a good
question yeah yeah that's a good
question all the light cells always the
light cells in all environments that's
something we haven't we haven't measured
yet that's all going that so that's also
a good question so our hypothesis going
in to that was that we were going to
knock out the delayed onset place fields
that those were the only ones that
required synaptic plasticity and the
instant ones would would remain but
that's naturally not true we see both
types even in the knockout so even at
the late onset place field doesn't
require ca1 synaptic plasticity but that
doesn't mean plasticity isn't occurring
elsewhere in the campus or even
elsewhere in the circuit yes so you
mentioned Jeff McGee's work so more
recently he's been reporting that there
these massive depolarization potentials
coming from enter on a layer three
inputs to the basal well to the apical
dendrites and then propagating up so I
just want to use the model in your head
of how we should be thinking about this
that this is really sort of a
conjunctiva T or conjunction from C a 3
or CA 2 and the basal dendrites and this
massive input fermenter on all day
that's what's determining when the cell
should fire I think that's a great model
I think that that's probably likely true
yeah we can't with this method it's
difficult to detect on the apical side
because it's just geometric and deep in
the brain but that would be a great
experiment to see if we could see the
dendritic activity that relates to the
maguey signal that he sees down there
but yeah the idea would be if you have
high levels of branch spiking in the
Basil's
they're strong input in the apical side
that that would be enough to drive the
plasticity in the formation yeah so
we've looked at this formation of yields
relative behavior this scanning behavior
where the animals yes just wondering
that in New York data is there anything
behaviorally that I suggest when these
spikes and curl are inches or yeah yeah
yeah so we did look at it a little bit
based on your your finding there but the
first of all there's no head scanning so
you can't relate directly Brendon you
found but there's also the behavior so
smooth in this preparation they you
switch the environment the animal the
running is disrupted for one lap and
then they just run they just keep
running a she's a little slight slowing
down ER we haven't seen we try to
connect it to velocity and we didn't see
anything but we don't know what the
animals thinking or paying attention to
is the thing right they could be on that
lap noticing something in the distance
in the VR environment and that's enough
to trigger it right I just have one
caution urgent is this a kind of an
appropriate cautionary note in
interpreting these data you were
typically visualizing five to six seven
dendrites right we could boost it back
up and out to about twenty but is it
fair to say you're you're seeing a
fraction yes when you see a cell
expiring at the Sun you don't see any
dendrites firing it could be that
there's some generators just blasting
off absolutely someplace on that same
cell absolutely a little bit
uncomfortable you know I have vested
interest in this but I'm a little
uncomfortable on the conclusion that
after learning the dendrites aren't
firing anyone that Benjo it's all firing
off the money well there was some how
you sort of the sense of reduced
prevalence yes these presidents see it
but it could be as in other cases in the
brain where you have after learning you
have sort of fewer cells firing more
strongly perhaps you know you're
lowering the number of dendrites that's
firing and they're firing restaurant but
you just don't see them as much well in
other words because they're fewer of
them you're only in
a fraction of the dendrites they may be
more often to fall out of view or more
often if you miss their misses I'm just
saying kid guy how solid is that
conclusion that there are no dendrites
firing right well the one thing that we
did to address this was we added a
second plane of imaging in there so we
had the single dendritic plane like I
showed in the movie and then we would
ask how well does it predict if there's
no firing there firing in the other
layer and it's pretty good so if there's
no firing in one layer we typically
don't see any firing in the other layer
that's not necessarily true there's no
firing in the branches across this is
just the basal dendrites you know
there's the apical side in there there's
tons of input there so we don't know
about that
[Applause]